und jetzt kann ich mir Tino propala
einem der Bundesvorsitzende in der AFD
in Berlin sprechen guten Abend Herr
kropalla und die Frage an Sie Hand aufs
Herz ist das sind Wirklichkeit nicht der
Sieg von Björn höcke und der nicht des
neuen Landrates
ja guten Abend erstmal ist der Sieg von
Sesselmann der dort ein engagierten
Wahlkampf geleistet hat auch von meiner
Seite hier noch mal herzlichen
Glückwunsch an Robert Sesselmann
natürlich viel Verantwortung auch diese
Aufgabe anzunehmen und diese
Verantwortung muss er jetzt gerecht
werden wir gehen aber diese diesen Sieg
mit Demut an die Bürger haben klar
entschieden das ist Demokratie und ich
denke er wird für die Sonneberger eine
gute Politik als Landrat leisten er ist
dort verwurzelt er ist kommunalpolitisch
bereits tätig gewesen also von daher
haben die Bürger sich richtig
entschieden und ja es ist der Anfang für
sicherlich weitere Weise die wir mit der
AFD auch gerade auf kommunaler Ebene
feiern werden wie
viel Berg gesteckt denn nun in diesem
Waldweg
wissen Sie wir reden jetzt sicherlich
nicht die nächsten sechs sieben Minuten
über Björn höcke wir haben einen Robert
Sesselmann der dort die Kommunalwahl
gewonnen hat er hat doch diesen
Wahlkampf geleistet er hat ihn fast
allein auch gestemmt mit Unterstützung
natürlich auch das Landesverbandes und
das ist nicht groß genug herauszuheben
am Ende reden wir darüber was die
Probleme und Sorgen der Menschen vor Ort
sind und das hat sich auch dort ja ein
Stück weit
gebracht
das ist nämlich das sagen der Wahl die
Themen dieses Mal ist Wahlkampfes die
hatte der neue Landrat hier auch mit
bundespolitischen Themen geführt also
ganz viel den Blick aufgemacht über den
äh den Landkreis hinein ist eine
fruchtig vorprogrammiert das kann er ja
gar nicht ändern
zum Beispiel Friedensverhandlungen mit
nur moment mal also die genau diese
Themen die die Berliner Politik die auch
die Thüringer Erfurter Politik ja
vorangetrieben hat das sind die genau
die Themen und das sind vor allen Dingen
die Dinge die die Menschen vor Ort die
einfachen Menschen die Arbeiter die
Lehrer die Polizisten erleben und genau
diese Fehlentscheidung in Berlin in
Erfurt nehmen die Menschen vor Ort auch
wahr und das sind genau die Themen die
man anspricht natürlich sind das auch
bundespolitische Themen landespolitische
Themen aber jetzt Entschuldigung wer hat
den bundespolitische brandneuern gebaut
das war Friedrich Merz er hat Menschen
ausgegrenzt und wer Mauern baut möchte
mit denjenigen Menschen auf der anderen
Seite der Mauer nicht reden und diese
Mauern werden wir langsam einreißen wer
Mauern baut das kennen wir gerade als
mitteldeutsche als Ostdeutsche wird
sehen was daraus im Endeffekt übrig
bleibt er hat das geschafft
robertsesselmann und wir werden es auch
in Zukunft schaffen und Friedrich Merzen
sagen
wollen
wir haben uns dagegen seit ich eben
vielleicht nicht gut verstanden
ausgerechnet den Thüringen woher der
Verfassungsschutz die AFD als
rechtsextreme einstuft ist dieser Erfolg
jetzt gekommen und das ist ja ein Erfolg
das haben wir ja auch schon gesagt und
konzertiert ist das Signal also die
rechtsextremer desto erfolgreicher kann
man das so sagen
wissen sie die Menschen erleben gerade
was extrem bedeutet diese Transformation
die sie am Vorspiel ihres Beitrags
bereits gemacht haben diese
Transformation ist extrem was die
Bundesregierung hier abliefert ist
extrem weil die Menschen das merken hohe
Inflation migrationsprobleme hohe Preise
Kriminalität das sind extreme Positionen
die seit Jahren nicht gelöst werden im
übrigen auch von der Vorgängerregierung
seit 16 Jahren und wissen Sie dieses
rechts links oben unten Mitte
querdiagonal das wollen doch die Leute
überhaupt nicht mehr Wissen darum geht's
doch wirklich Leute und Bürger wollen
die Probleme lassen Sie mich bitte
aussehen die Leute möchten die Bürger
möchten die Probleme gelöst haben die
möchten Sie von der aktuellen Politik
gelöst haben ist völlig egal von wem sie
gelöst werden verstehen sie das und das
muss endlich mal ankommen diese
Schuldzuweisungen die ich heute den
ganzen Tag von anderen Parteien gehört
habe ich muss ein Stück weit Schmunzeln
genauso machen Sie weiter so die AFD
wurde durch immer stärker wenn man nicht
endlich anfängt Probleme zu lösen jetzt
lassen Sie mich bitte noch eine letzte
Frage stellen wenn es geht wo sie eben
gerade das Thema extrem und Extremismus
aufgenommen haben sie folgender
letztendlich
angefangen ja im vergangenen Parteitag
vor knapp einem Jahr hat er gesagt dir
bestimmt selbst wäre Extremist ist ist
das richtig so
wissen Sie wir sind die Alternative für
Deutschland wir haben ein Parteiprogramm
das ist unsere Leitlinie nach dem
Verfahren wir dass es unsere Leitlinie
für unsere Kandidaten für unsere ganze
gesamte Partei ich nehme jetzt nicht
einzelne Aussagen von parteimit die dann
auf fragen sie bitte Björn höcke selbst
machen sie mit ihnen Interview fragen
Sie ihm was er damit gemeint hat ich bin
der Parteivorsitzende der gesamten
Partei ich freue mich für dieses
Ergebnis ich freue mich für die
Thüringer dass damit ein Startschuss
begonnen ist das war erst der Anfang wir
werden weitere Mauern einreißen zum
Wohle Deutschland zum Mode Thüringens
sagt Timo krupala einer der
Bundesvorsitzenden der AFD